i want now to turn to the changes we
propose to the current rules on
self-isolation to ensure that they
remain reasonable and proportionate
let me be clear at the outset that these
those who have symptoms of
or who test positive for covered will
still be required
to self-isolate as now however from 9th
august an adult who is
identified as a close contact of someone
who has tested positive
will no longer be required automatically
to self-isolate for 10 days
instead if someone is double vaccinated
with at least
two weeks since the second dose and if
they have no symptoms
they should get a pcr test as soon as
possible and if the pcr test is negative
self-isolation can then be ended his pcr
results come back quickly frequently
within 24 hours
this will greatly reduce the amount of
time that many people will need to spend
in
self-isolation we're proposing a similar
change for people age 17
or under most of whom of course are not
yet
eligible for vaccination if a young
person aged 5 to 17 is identified as a
closed contact they will need to take a
pcr test
but they can end their self-isolation if
they test negative
children under the age of five will be
encouraged but not required
to get pcr tests in addition test and
protect will implement
revised guidance for under-18s including
in schools
this means that the blanket isolation of
whole
classes will no longer be routine
instead a more targeted approach will
identify
close contacts at higher highest risk of
infection
the fear young people will be asked to
self-isolate and
most will be asked to self-isolate for a
much daughter period
of time obviously this is especially
important as we approach the start of
the new
school year so let me turn to the wider
arrangements for the return of schools
and updated guidance is being published
today as a consequence of the new
approach to self-isolation which is
important to minimise disruption to
education
and in line with advice from our expert
advisory subgroup on education
we have decided to retain for the first
six weeks of the new academic term
most of the other mitigations that are
currently in place in schools
this also reflects the unique
environment of schools where large
numbers of
unvaccinated children and young people
mix with adult staff
so for up to six weeks subject then to
review there will be a continued
requirement for staff to keep at least
a metre distance from each other and
from children and young people while in
the school estate
and we've also decided after careful
consideration
to retain the current requirements for
face coverings
in schools for staff and for children
aged 12 or over
that includes asking young people and
staff in secondary schools to wear face
coverings during lessons
and while inside school buildings i am
acutely aware that many many young
people find this really difficult
and so it will be kept under review but
for now we consider this an important
protection
for them and for others in the school
the expert advisory subgroup has also
emphasized the importance of good
ventilation
and we are therefore strengthening
guidance in this regard
many local authorities have already
taken steps to improve ventilation
in the schooling state and this work has
highlighted the value
of co2 monitors these devices are useful
in assessing how well ventilated a space
is
and therefore how likely it is that the
virus could be present
the new guidance published today makes
clear that all schools and daycare
services for children
must have access to co2 monitoring
through either fixed or mobile devices
and that these should be used to assess
the quality
of ventilation in schools and child care
settings and identify
any necessary improvements these
assessments will be ongoing obviously
over the coming weeks but we expect them
to be completed and necessary
improvements identified
by the october half term and i can
confirm today that we are making
available to local authorities
an additional 10 million pounds to
support this work
ventilation is one of the most important
ways in which the risk of covet
transmission can be reduced and so
improving it will be vital now and in
the future
to ensure that schools and childcare
centres are as safe as possible
finally local authorities and schools
will ask all secondary pupils and all
school staff
to take a lateral flow test one or two
days before
returning after the holidays and then to
take tests twice a week after that
this continues to be an important
additional way in which people
in which covert can be identified even
in people who do not have symptoms
we're also working with the further in
higher education sector on plans for the
year ahead
specific guidance on operating beyond
level zero for universities and colleges
has now been published in addition
students will be encouraged to take a
pcr test
before any move to term-time
accommodation and then to test twice a
week after that
dating officer the last year and a half
has been and this
inevitably will be an understatement uh
it has been difficult and stressful for
children and young people
parents and all staff working in
education settings
i am so grateful to them for the
understanding and cooperation shown
the new school and academic term will
still bring challenges i think there is
little doubt of that
but i hope it will also bring fewer
disruptions
and also allow a much more normal
learning environment for all
of our young people